I don't think you have a whole lot
babban he just shook his head rappin
doesn't know a whole lot and honestly
could be very frank I think this could
be the best episode of daily be ever hey
guys we're gonna try to figure out
something for today's episode literally
the entire day is predicated on internal
meetings that we can't show so we're
trying to sit here figure out how we're
gonna hack it maybe on some of my drives
I'll do some rants talk a State of Union
why don't you have the team talk you
know what we'll do tonight we'll social
commentate on some of the business
things that are happening in the world
so why are you in the team look at some
of the headlines two cents on towards
Russ going out of business let me just
talk to you guys about why toys-r-us
trip filing chapter 11 matters Toys R Us
[Music]
did two things over the last couple
decades that make no sense one very
early in the 2000s they outsource
themselves to Amazon they didn't believe
in the Internet 17 years ago so that
Amazon do their fulfillment which
started people getting used to buying
toys on the internet through an Amazon
world but most importantly they just
didn't innovate you know and when you
don't innovate you die like you could
have made Toys Toys R Us 3 years ago
could have created the National Lego
Championships and everybody would be
there was there was a million they could
have made slime centers they could have
they could be killing it right now with
their locations but no they choose to
just like sell toys out of it and none
of you want to go there first of all
you're gonna go to Walmart and pick it
up for less money anyway
while you pick up your groceries
anything else and if you even want to
leave your [ __ ] home and you don't
and so you'll go to Amazon and do it
that way or buy it from somebody's
YouTube channel link or you know
Instagram account it's just it's it's
the best example right now of like how
in trouble everybody is if they [ __ ]
rest on their laurels
you know if Toys R Us the dominant niche
retail leader of a humongous
multi-billion dollar category is
finished what do you think is gonna
happen over the next six years you know
classic day being CEO of pic
companies really yeah I've been really
in it right like we're [ __ ] in it
we're [ __ ] in it
[Music]
[Music]
that's what is it just new well we're
probably connected glasses connected
glasses yeah glasses that talk yeah boys
I like it dude it guys every single
thing is gonna interact with every
single thing
go find a clip right now when you
talking about smart pants everything the
world will be smart your shirt your
pants your underwear your sneakers your
socks that's what I think about smart
glasses this coffee cup is gonna tell me
that this coffee is cold it's gonna give
me a recommendation of a cool coffee
that's gonna automatically order it
through my phone show up here I mean I
wasn't pretty impressed with his reddit
kids uh content to be sent through yeah
internship is on my resume in the
content we've leveled up content
business now we're just media media
conglomerate around one human being
savage in there
don't by walking into a roundtable
discussion so the first part is just you
know home lending plus see yeah this is
more business dishes to follow up from
that yes good yeah my my in a like I was
making a joke that I don't know what I'm
doing until the morning when I take
first glance at it the fact that I don't
know what I'm doing 20 minutes whole
nother level I just don't know what I'm
doing hey kids the key to success is not
knowing client experience of the world
Joe Whitmarsh show Joe
long time that the media made that joke
earlier CEO like just 800 emails 1500
texts I think there's just not enough
appreciation for the amount of volume of
work and effort and energy just energy
needed to sit on top of something
successful a lot of people want these
big companies that you guys all want to
build I just want to make sure everybody
understands the emotional drainage that
is happening in real time
make sure your energy is up that's why
you meant to hell he's got to be right
[Music]
long day 8:24 p.m. New York about to go
into two meetings of the clients the
whole day I don't think you have a whole
lot babban he just shook his head
Abin doesn't know a whole lot and
honestly could be very frank I think
this could be the best episode of daily
be ever make it shortest [ __ ] show it
what it is it's real simple like just a
lot of [ __ ] work a lot of grinding
every day is different
not every day super fun glamorous even
with [ __ ] some cool up-and-coming
hip-hop music some interesting at its
some different angles like sometimes
YouTube it just is what it is right like
babban can only do so much
you know just [ __ ] 15 hours of
[ __ ] hustling today client client
client client client client client you
know just what it was just what it is
it's actually what it is a whole lot of
the time luckily I love right that's all
it really [ __ ] is like we find our
you know the speeches help the
travelling helps but like it's yeah man
the whole thing's [ __ ] boring you
know I'm a little bit entertaining as a
personality and I'm putting out I'm
showing and talking about stuff that
matters to people if they're really
paying attention watch what I do not
what I say we you know I didn't think
that's not boring is it's [ __ ] real
it's the [ __ ] truth and so for every
one of you trying to get yours in your
genre in your world your way no special
effects are more powerful than true
story the story always wins
[Music]
yeah me and the whole thing's [ __ ]
boring